[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
en direct bienvenue dans ça vous regarde
à la une ce soir lakovic 19 une maladie
socialement inégalitaire on va revenir
sur cette vaste enquête de l'inserm
rendues publiques aujourd'hui premier
portrait à grande échelle des personnes
les plus touchées par le virus et sans
surprise ce sont les plus pauvres un
million de français ont par ailleurs
basculer dans la pauvreté depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire on en parle
dans un instant avec nos invités dans
notre grand débat on viendra aussi sur
la libération de sophie et ronan la
dernière otage française dans le monde a
atterri à villacoublay
c'était à la mi journée elle a été
accueillie par le président de la
république emmanuel macron une
libération qui coïncide avec la remise
en liberté de plusieurs dizaines de
jihadistes l'analyse du journaliste
antoine glaser spécialiste de l'afrique
et du mali sur ce plateau et puis notre
grand témoin ce soir observe les
battements du monde depuis des années un
journaliste il a été patron france
télévisions et surtout amoureux de la
politique il a signé pour être cp une
série de documentaires sur les secrets
de la cinquième république patrice
duhamel est avec nous ce soir voilà donc
pour le programme c'est parti hashed
accès vers n'oubliez pas tout de suite
le grand débarras
[Musique]
bonsoir patrice duhamel juin merci
d'être avec nous on va commenter
l'actualité en votre compagnie pendant
toute l'heure on va revenir sur la
libération de sophie petronas jeudi des
sur ces images très fortes elles sont
toujours très fortes mais
particulièrement aujourd'hui à
villacoublay on va parler aussi de votre
travail notamment deux documentaristes
vous en êtes à plusieurs documentaires à
votre actif vous connaissez mieux que
personne la vème république on y
reviendra mais on commence avec cette
photographie inédite cette enquête de
l'inserm avec l'insee et santé publique
france elle a été publiée aujourd'hui et
elle dresse en quelque sorte le premier
véritable portrait à grande échelle des
personnes les plus touchées par le virus
manuel domergue bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes responsable
des études à la fondation abbé pierre
les associations qui estiment à un
million
c'est un chiffre énorme 1 millions de
nouveaux pauvres depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire et on parle de ce sujet
avec vous également stéphane troussel
bonsoir merci à d'être là vous êtes le
président socialiste du département de
la seine saint denis l'un des plus
touchés le plus touché peut-être de tout
le pays par ce virus dans quelques
minutes à peine de jean-philippe bail et
mbaye député la république en marche du
val de marne va nous rejoindre et
bonsoir stéphane bon sourire blakowski
qui m'accompagne comme chaque soir et
qui va ouvrir cette émission avec son
billet si j'ai bien compris tout de
suite
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris ce soir c'est alors
si j'ai bien compris myriam le plus
inquiétant finalement avec cette crise
du que big ben ce ne sont peut-être pas
ses conséquences sanitaires mais ses
conséquences économiques en tout cas
quand on pose aujourd'hui la question
aux français et bien ce qui les inquiète
le plus ce n'est pas leur propre santé
c'est la santé de l'économie française
ou non je vous laisse regarder les
chiffres de l'ifop voyez il ya moins de
70% des français qui s'inquiètent pour
leur santé 87 % qui s'inquiètent pour
l'économie et le plus inquiétant c'est
sans doute le chômage alors là c'est
vrai qu'elle est prévu les prévisions
sont vraiment très alarmante je vous
rappelle qu'au début de l'année on était
autour de 8% de chômage là la banque de
france nous dit qu'on devrait être
au-dessus de 10% à la fin de l'année et
qu'on devrait même dépasser
les 11% l'année prochaine en 2021 donc
là ce que je suis en train de vous dire
c'est qu'on est au tout début de la
crise économique certains pas vraiment
s'aggraver dans les mois qui viennent
mais en attendant que le pire arrive
déjà aujourd'hui on a des situations
désastreuses et avait un article dans le
titre est assez frappant dans le monde
l'autre jour je propose de le regarder
voiliers qui annonçait que vous l'avez
dit d'ailleurs dans votre titre qu'il ya
désormais un million de nouveaux de
français qui ont basculé dans la
propreté donc ça veut dire que l'an
dernier il y avait eu plus de neuf
millions de français qui vivait donc
avec moins 1000 63 euros par personne
ils sont désormais 10 millions donc ça
se traduit on va en parler j'imagine les
loyers impayés plus d'inscrits au rsa et
même le plus douloureux des gens qui ont
du mal à s'acheter à manger en ce moment
alors la grande question comme à chaque
fois donc tourner étaient passés au fond
qu'est-ce qu'on fait que fait le
gouvernement alors pour l'instant le
gouvernement réfléchit pas se précipiter
non plus le premier ministre a reçu les
associations de lutte contre la pauvreté
vendredi dernier il a écouté leurs
revendications ce que j'avais à lui dire
et puis le 17 octobre il devrait
annoncer de nouvelles mesures alors en
attendant qu'est ce qui s'est passé on a
tous entendu parler de ce plan de 100
milliards de relance de la france dont
10 sur 100 milliards ira bien qu'il
pièces pour les pauvres voilà une petite
pièce j'aurais 10 1 % de la somme pour
les pauvres on n'y est pas verrouillée
pour cent seulement servir 800 millions
qui devraient consacrer un soutien des
plus précaires alors forcément les
associations vous faites partis
réclament d'autres mesures par exemple
plutôt que de supprimer la taxe
d'habitation pour les 20% de français
les plus riches qui va être mise en
oeuvre dès 2021 est-ce qu'on ne pourrait
pas utiliser cet argent pour aider les
plus pauvres dont c'est le calcul café
christophe de l'iss qui est le porte
parole va dire d'alert c'est-à-dire un
collectif d'associations rencontre de
lutte contre la pauvreté on écoute ce
petit calcul pour vous donner un exemple
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
pour les 20% les plus riches ces huit à
neuf milliards d'euros une augmentation
ne serait-ce que de 10% du revenu de
solidarité
il était honni solidarités actives le
rsa c'est 1,2 milliard voyez 8 milliards
prince pression taxe d'habitation 1
milliard sur l'augmenter pour cent le
rsa alors je sais pas vous fait que je
suis trop samson mais là je me pose une
question quand même je me demande si le
gouvernement ne devrait pas en faire
petit peu plus pour aider ceux qui sont
en train de plonger dans la pauvreté à
cause du club à se poser la question ce
soir merci stéphane avant de connaître
vos demandes vos attentes les
associations j'aimerais qu'on revienne
sur l'état des lieux qui sont ces
nouveaux pour
la banque alimentaire qui n'arrivent
plus à boucler leurs femmes mais les
nouveaux pauvres qui ont basculé dans la
pauvreté était déjà des personnes qui
étaient assez fragile vous savez on a un
système de protection sociale en france
qui protège bien ceux qui sont déjà bien
protégé terre les personnes qui étaient
en cdi qui étaient fonctionnaires n'ont
pas spécialement souffert du point de
vue social de la crise économique et
sanitaire qu'on a connu en revanche les
personnes qui étaient sur le fil du
point de vue de l'emploi qui étaient en
cdd en stage en intérim les saisonniers
les intermittents je suis en cdd je suis
pas renouvelé mais je suis pas assez
pauvre pour toucher le chômage enfin
revenu souvent contre qu'il fasse en
fonction du nombre de mois qu'on a
travaillé on a droit ou pas au chômage
vous savez que le gouvernement venait de
faire passer une réforme qui durcissent
et les conditions d'accès à
l'indemnisation chômage donc il ya des
millions de personnes qui ont perdu des
revenus certains sont rattrapés par les
aides de l'état les indemnisations
certains sont rattrapés par les les
allocations chômage et d'autres passent
à travers ou vont passer à travers au
furet qui n'ont pas cotisé assez
longtemps annonçant forcément le chômage
mais c'est évidemment au dessus
c'est ça alors c'est pour ça que cette
crise aussi va mettre du temps parce que
vous savez entre le moment où votre
entreprise à des difficultés financières
le moment où elle arrête son activité où
elle vous licencie ou vous venez au bout
de vos droits aux allocations chômage ça
peut prendre plusieurs mois voire
plusieurs années et avant que vous
n'arriviez plus à payer votre loyer vos
charges vos remboursements d'emprunts
après avoir demandé de l'aide à votre
famille consommer votre épargne ça peut
prendre plusieurs plusieurs années donc
c'est cette crise est appelée à durer
longtemps c'est pour ça que les les
aides ponctuelles ne sont pas à la
hauteur de la crise montre la photo
sociologique on parle beaucoup des
jeunes des étudiants mais vous dites
vous même que ce sont aussi des gens qui
travaillent des artisans des commerçants
oui alors il ya plusieurs temporalités
les personnes qui qui s'en vont des
secteurs qui sont touchés vont mettre
plusieurs mois à plusieurs années à
avoir leur situation se dégrader en
revanche comme dans toutes les crises
ceux qui sont les perdants les plus
rapides ce sont les personnes qui
n'avaient pas de situations parade on
est donc en particulier jeunes qui
finissent leurs études au qui aurait
voulu aller poursuivre et qui arrivent
sur le marché de l'emploi le marché du
logement sans aucun à tous et sans
aucune perspective en vue il faut se
mettre à la place de quelqu'un qui vient
d'avoir son bac son ca paie son master
sa licence qu'est ce qui fait
aujourd'hui on va les entendre ces
personnes dans un instant dans un
reportage stéphane troussel vous qu'est
ce que vous observez concernés on
imagine que voilà toutes les demandes
dette sociale explose oui c'est
exactement ce qui vient d'être décrit
c'est à dire qu'il ya à la fois les
demandes notamment du rsa puisque ce
sont les départements qui verse le rsa
et donc on a une augmentation très forte
dans un département déjà populaires
comme la seine-saint-denis mais ce
constat là il est en train de s'établir
sur d'autres départements qui n'étaient
pas forcément dans ce type de situation
précédemment donc on a une augmentation
très forte dans certains départements on
est déjà 10 11 14 % en seine-saint-denis
je pense qu'on finira l'année entre 6 et
8% d'augmentation c'est plusieurs
dizaines de millions d'euros
supplémentaires qu'il faut trouver pour
le département qu'est ce qu'elle vous
dise dans quel état d'esprit elle sont
ces nouveaux pots à ce qu'ils ont peur
est ce qu'ils vont montrer oui bien sûr
ils ont peur il ya aussi de la honte
comme vous dites c'est exactement les
profils que monsieur vient d'indiquer
c'est à dire que on a un certain nombre
de salariés qui eux ont des droits
notamment l'indemnisation du chômage
parfois le chômage partiel et puis il ya
tous les autres des des petits le marché
du travail ces dernières années c'est
que quand même considérablement
précarisés flexibiliser donc avec des
tout petits emplois de courte durée des
de l'intérim des cdd des jobs parfois
même pas toujours pas toujours comment
dirais-je encadrer et réguler et donc
quand on quand il ya ce confinement eh
bien il ya d'abord tout cela qu'ils
perdent immédiatement leurs activités et
puis à ce qui arrive maintenant dont le
contrat n'a pas été renouvelé dont le
cdi a été interrompu pour cause de lille
on n'arrive plus à payer le loyer on
n'arrive plus à se soigner nous inquiète
considérablement ses notamment les
jeunes je rappelle que nous sommes un
des rares pays européens où les jeunes
n'ont pas accès aux minima sociaux et
donc cela en ce moment il n'en reste
plus rien du tout plus le petit job qui
accompagnent des études pas toujours la
solidarité nationale la solidarité
familiale qui peut continuer de jouer et
a accès au rsa donc ça c'est une
situation très dramatique patrice
duhamel
c'est une forme de crise sociale on est
déjà en train
c'est oui à millions de nouveaux pauvres
et au total plus de 10 millions est en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté c'est
d'autant plus inquiétant que on est dans
une période tout à fait étonnante est
totalement inédite avec un état qui est
plus protecteur qui n'a pas été depuis
des dizaines et des dizaines d'années on
a vu ce qui a été fait sur le chômage
partiel on voit ce qui est fait pour le
soutien aux entreprises donc c'est une
stratégie et c'est aussi une demande de
la société française dans cette période
de crise sanitaire
juste deux choses d'abord si on décline
le fameux quoi qu'il en coûte du
président de la république dans sa
première intervention au moment de
l'heure
de l'entrée dans l annonce du
confinement oui
j'imagine mal je ne sais pas ce qui sera
ce qui vous sera annoncée le 17 octobre
j'imagine mal que le gouvernement n'est
pas également une stratégie de soutien à
la demande puisqu'il a choisi termes
stratégiques la politique de l'offre est
bien soutien aux entreprises pour
essayer de limiter la l'augmentation du
chômage
limité au maximum si c'est si c'est
possible mais j'imagine mal qu'il n'y
ait qui rien de prévu dans le dispositif
gouvernemental pour aider non seulement
ces deux nouveaux pots mais les pauvres
en général c'est le quoi qu'il en coûte
qui a une dimension économique et qui
devrait donc pas vu mais moi j'ai aucun
conseil à donner au nom de quoi je vois
pas pourquoi qui devrait avoir une
dimension sociale et effectivement on
attend un peu pour savoir justement ce
qui pourraient être annoncés ou est-ce
que les pauvres sont les grands oubliés
de cette cette relance je vous propose
qu'on les entende ces personnes un fils
né râble obligés parfois pour la
première fois de recourir à la banque
alimentaire nathalie gloire s'est rendu
aux restos du coeur une antenne par
vienne reportage
81 18
10h ce matin et la 100ème personne va
bientôt passer la porte des restos du
coeur depuis le confinement ils sont de
plus en plus nombreux à tyr ambre
awa à 40 ans elle fait partie de ces
nouveaux bénéficiaires liée aux qu'ovide
les touches g les voir des concerts j'ai
des papes
elle est mère de sept enfants elle vit
seule et l'épidémie est tout fait
basculer voilà c'était dur parce qu'on
était tous les enfants la maison et
fallait faire à manger le matin à midi
et le soir et c'était pas facile de
gérer tous les enfants à la maison et
les moyens n'étaient pas au quoi ce
débat et le reste des cas nous a
vraiment sauvé la vie aujourd'hui elle
est très inquiète pour son avenir moi
j'ai
1500g travaillant j'ai travaillé ici en
congé parental depuis confinement se
devine très doux même les achats même
les pouces tout ça est devenu très vite
et awa n'est pas la seule dans ce cas là
dans les files d'attentes les bénévoles
sont surpris par la présence de
nouvelles personnes
cette semaine on
oncle de personnes plus âgées
qui sortait un peu de
ce
qu'on a l'habitude de voir
ici il semblerait que c'était des
personnes qui avaient tout perdu pendant
le confinement astrid la responsable de
cette structure le confirme de plus en
plus de nouveaux profils ont débarqué
aux restos du coeur résultat ici le
nombre de bénéficiaires a augmenté de
100% ces derniers mois aujourd'hui un
peu plus de nouvelles personnes qu'on
n'avait jamais vu qu'ils continuent à
venir il ya beaucoup de femmes seules
avec les enfants des gens la retraite
des travailleurs qui touchait enfin
pauvreté travailleurs touchent peu
d'argent qu'ils travaillent que deux
trois heures et qui ont ils vraiment des
petits salaires ce sont des gens qui se
trouvent dans une situation difficile
son travail qui ont des enfants qui ont
des crédits des dettes un loyer à payer
et donc ils sont obligés d essayer de se
nourrir
par les moyens qui peuvent ce centre
enregistre une quarantaine
d'inscriptions par jour astrid redoute
elle aujourd'hui la deuxième vague du
coronavirus et j'accueille avec les airs
gens filmés mbaye bonsoir pour ce
témoin vous êtes député la république en
marche du val de marne joyeux regardez
ce reportage attentivement et ces mères
de familles souvent maman solo comme on
dit maintenant qu'ils se demandent
comment elles vous faire pour nourrir
tout simplement leur famille vous en
avez dans votre circonscription c'est un
cri de désespoir permettant à dire
qu'ils quittent insoutenable à entendre
dans notre pays à l'heure où
effectivement ou traversons cette cette
crise sanitaire et vous avez raison de
le dire dans mon département qui est un
département de banlieue département du
val de marne effectivement que nous
avons ce genre de situation je me suis
moi même entretenu avec des acteurs
comme la croix rouge
comme les acteurs associatifs
qui nous font remonter ce genre de
situation cei les épiceries solidaires
dans des quartiers prioritaires de la
ville ça affluent le monde afflue et
donc effectivement on est très très
sensibilisés à cette à cette question il
va falloir oui rapidement que l'on passe
de cette situation je dirais
conjoncturel une situation de pauvretés
conjoncturelles pour ne pas qu'elle
devienne une situation de pauvreté
structure cendres cours au rsa au niveau
du pays 30 % les loyers à payer
notamment dans l'est dans les hlm la
banque alimentaire on le voit avant
votre arrivée stéphane blakowski
expliquer que finalement seulement
0,8 pour cent des 100 milliards du plan
de relance était consacrée aux plus
pauvres est ce suffisant c'est sûr que
c'est pas le c'est pas le il y aura
jamais de de caractère suffisant je
crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut absolument
oui il faut absolument corriger ça il
faut qu'ils aient un acte fort sur le
plan de pauvreté il faut que le deuxième
acte malheureusement du plan de pauvreté
qui qui succède à ce premier plan de
provoquer qui avait été annoncé il faut
qu'il soit plus fort que ça mais vous
parliez de ces hommes et de ces femmes
qui sont au rsa qui sont à la banque
alimentaire voyez vous il ya une
catégorie par exemple de personnes dont
true parle très peu dans l'opinion
publique c'est la question des permis
tant de l'événementiel c'est extra de
l'événementiel qui représente entre 15
et 20 mille personnes moi avec mon
collègue sénateur aviez iacovelli nous
sommes en train de finaliser une
proposition de loi parce qu'il faut
sortir ces gens
il ya des trous face dans le filet de la
sécurité ce sont quinze à vingt mille
personnes aujourd'hui qu'ils ont déjà
commencé à soi hypothéquer leur maison
soit allé dans des banques alimentaires
qui ne peuvent même plus touché le rsa
et ces gens là personne n'en parle je
regarde encore toutes les manifestations
pacifiques qu'elles ont pu tenir depuis
un certain temps ça n'a alerté et ça
n'allait me personnes et donc nous avec
le sénateur à vie iacovelli nous sommes
emparés de cette situation et nous
alarment étant prochainement pas des
intermittents du spectacle les deux les
résidents on appelle la section athlé
maintenant de l'événementiel dans la
restauration c'est différent car oui
vous même vous vous entretenez cette
confusion parce que personne n'en parle
vingt mille personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui dans une détresse totale et
donc il faut en parler il faut
solutionner ce problème là et nous
devons le faire parce que sinon ce sont
des familles entières qui sont dévastés
n'engendraient savoir exactement ce que
vous attendez à la fondation abbé pierre
y avait ce plan pauvreté après tout il
n'a que deux ans il y avait ses idées de
de service public de l'emploi avec
des petits déjeuners qui devaient être
distribués dans le dans les écoles il y
avait aussi cette idée d'un revenu
universel
d'activité où on en est mais on en n'est
nulle part on a fait un an et demi de
concertation avec le gouvernement
jusqu'à ce que la personne en charge de
cette concertation démissionne la
secrétaire d'état à la lutte contre la
pauvreté n'a pas été renouvelé le poste
est vacant donc le et rue a est un
projet qui est enterré en fait
universels d'activité qui devait
fusionner les minima sociaux lutter
contre le non recours l'ouvrir d'une
certaine manière peut-être aux moins de
25 ans donc il y avait quand même une
ambition et puis ben voilà c'est à la
poubelle pour quelle raison on nous a
dit à cause du coc vie depuis ça n'a
aucun rapport donc c'est vraiment on
sent qu'il ya pas de volonté politique
ça a été dit et 0 8% du plan de relance
consacré aux personnes les plus
vulnérables bon ben là on est on sait de
l'ordre de la blague le plan pauvreté
numéro un on va servir des petits
déjeuners dans les bus ça c'est très
bien c'est très bien mais ils ont été
servis oui oui oui c'est formidable
vraiment fort petit déjeuner aux
personnes qui ont pas assez d'argent
pour s'acheter la cantine qui d'ailleurs
s'est arrêté pendant le confinement à un
euro ça faisait partie bon alors
beaucoup de plongée déjà c'est un on est
on est de l'ordre des choses qui sont
très bien très intéressante mais agir
c'est pas ça la lutte contre la pauvreté
ça c'est ça c'est du gadget politique
stéphane troussel là-dessus leur
pauvreté oui c'est très bien les repas
un euro mais la plupart des
collectivités locales aujourd'hui elles
font elles ont un premier tarif qui est
inférieur à 1 euro le premier tarif en
seine saint denis dans les collèges il
est à 0 50 euro deux cent cinquante
centimes d'euros dont vous voyez bien
que ça relevait davantage du gadget je
vais vous donner un chiffre / / / cette
année je ne sais plus c'est l'an dernier
ou cette année le département de la
seine saint denis qui a signé avec le
gouvernement cette stratégie de la lutte
contre la pauvreté je crois que nous
avons dû percevoir l'année dernière
cette année trois millions et quelques
d'euros peut-être six l'année suivante
lorsque le doigt le département payer
chaque année au titre du rsa puisque
c'est l'état qui s'est déchargé depuis
15 ans du paiement du rsa c'est
département sur les départements cette
année ses 200 millions d'euros donc bien
évidemment que j'ai signé la stratégie
pauvreté avec le gouvernement pour
récupérer quelques est aujourd'hui lyon
d'euros par long de la seine saint denis
si koné très bien j'ai bien dit
particulièrement touché mais pour les
gens des calissons jean la pauvreté ou
qui y sont déjà sont aussi on va y venir
ceux qui attrapent le plus le candidat
parce qu'ils vivent dans des dans des
hlm où il ya beaucoup des tâches qu'on
appuie sur l'ascenseur et ses accès des
premiers de de corvée dans l'est dans
les supermarchés et caméras vous voyez
bien le décalage et puis quand même ce
débat sur la lutte contre la pauvreté il
n'intervient pas dans n'importe quel
contexte ça fait trois ans que le
gouvernement a fait d'autres choix sur
d'autres questions auxquelles paris
tout à l'heure on évoquait par exemple
la question de la taxe d'habitation ou
même un certain nombre de quêtes de
choix fiscaux liés à l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune lié à la flat
tax il ya une étude qui vient d'être
rendue sur le fait que depuis trois ans
bien écouté il n'y a pas de
ruissellement comme on nous l'avait
laissé entendre c'est tout l'inversé les
riches se sont enrichis et les pauvres
se sont appauvris et donc au moment où
on a cette crise sanitaire avec des
conséquences économiques et sociales
dramatiques il faut changer de cap
urgemment je m'attende vers les députés
de la majorité que vous êtes du côté des
départs france au pardon mais c'est
décidément le sport terminée je fais
plus les rares jean françois et mbaye
qu'est ce que vous répondez non mais
c'est sûr que ce que je viens de vous
dire tout à l'heure et est aujourd'hui
mise en mise en lumière c'est à dire que
on a une situation aujourd'hui
conjoncturelle qui vient se superposer
une situation structurelle dans certains
départements et prison du conseil
départemental de seine-saint-denis l'a
rappelé moi je vois les engagements que
l'état a en tout cas mis sur ce
département après faut aller beaucoup
plus loin beaucoup plus vite que je suis
là je m'explique vos effet la carte
l'opposition mais aussi les associations
c'est que les plus pauvres serait d'une
certaine façon les grands oubliés de ce
quinquennat non non non non moi je ne
l'accepterai pas ce procès là enfin on a
aujourd'hui dans ce pays il a mis en
place un certain nombre de dispositifs
avant la crise d'accord pendant la crise
pendant le pic de la crise on avait
commencé à les mettre avant même que
cette crise interviennent et sur
lesquels aujourd'hui il faut avoir un
autre regard en tenant compte du
contexte je vous donne un exemple le
conseil national de lutte contre
l'exclusion vient de publier son rapport
il ya un certain nombre de propositions
mais qui sont tout à fait parlants qui
sont même alarmante et donc pour
lesquels aujourd'hui il va falloir que
nous parlementaires je ne dis pas
simplement les parlementaires de la
majorité vit l'ensemble des
parlementaires ayant un regard sur les
propositions qui sont formulées elles
sont au nombre de douze mois il y en a
sur lesquels je me reconnais totalement
sur lesquels il y un levier d'action à
faire
écouter tous les parlementaires l'ont
reçu vous avez une députée de la
majorité
madame lazare qui en est la présidente
de ce conseil national de lutte contre
l'excision et qui est d'ailleurs très au
fait de ces questions elle est dans le
département du val d'oise elle connaît
ses problématiques donc c'est là aussi
ces leviers là qui va falloir active et
très très rapidement dire que les les
plus pauvres ont été les oubliés
de cette de cette gestion de crise et
qui ramène à la pauvreté dans des
cantons a mis un certain nombre de
dispositifs tels que le temps partiel
garanti quand on a effectivement quand
on s'est battus et vous pour réhausser
le plafond des tickets restaurants des
salariés qui étaient à temps par
s'inquiéter en télétravail et qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas l'excusé quand on s'est
battu pour ces mêmes tickets restaurant
puisse être utilisé dans les
supermarchés que le plafond soit relevé
je ne pense pas qu'on ait eu un regard
qu'on n'ait pas eu de regard envers les
plus modestes et les familles les plus
modestes mais je suis je suis d'accord
avec vous il y a encore des choses à
faire il faut encore amplifier cette ce
regard et cette action il ya une
question plus stratégiques qui se pose
le gouvernement il a choisi il a
expliqué il a assumé on l'a encore vu
hier avec les dernières décisions de
bruno le maire sur un certain nombre de
nouveaux secteurs soutenus et c'est face
à la crise mais il a fixé comme cap la
stratégie de l'offre c'est-à-dire un
soutien aux entreprises je disais tout à
l'heure pour éviter qu'ils aient une
augmentation trop trop massive du
chômage est ce que vous ne pensez pas
qu'il devrait y avoir un volet
significatif maintenant là où on en est
avec ses plus de 10 millions de deux
personnes en france vivent en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté sur une politique de
la demande c'est-à-dire un soutien à la
consommation une aide à la consommation
comme ça se fait d'ailleurs je crois en
allemagne dans d'autres pays européens
notamment ce qu'on pensait pas que c'est
vraiment maintenant on est dans
l'urgence monsieur delfraissy viennent
nous annoncer que la crise sanitaire
elle allait durer jusqu'à l'été prochain
c'est à dire encore 10 mois
bon je sais pas quels sont les éléments
qui permettent de dire s'est dit ce
n'est pas 8 ou 12 je ne sais pas mais
enfin en tout cas on est dans le moyen
terme
est-ce qu'il faut pas un plan de soutien
à la consommation et notamment aux
foyers les plus modestes mais je suis
d'accord avec vous vraiment il faut
aller vite quoi on est on est dans la
discussion budgétaire alors non je viens
de vous dire je viens de vous dire que
le conseil national de l'exclusion vient
de rendre son rapport et qu'il y à là
dedans douze propositions sur lesquelles
il faut agir aujourd'hui sont urgents
1021 je ne suis pas peuvent être dans le
budget 2021 sinon ça c'est notre le
parlementaire et oui de faire en sorte
c'est ce que je vous dis je viens de
vous dire que ces mesures là il y en a
que y en a il ya des mesures sur
lesquelles moi je me reconnais sur
lesquelles on va agir et qu'on va le
faire et ce sera dans le budget il y a
deux choses il y a le plan de relance
qui a permis d'avoir une certaine
certain matelas on va dire une certaine
stabilité et puis il y a ce qu'il faut
maintenant pérenniser dans un projet de
loi de finances au regard de ce nouveau
contexte là vous avez parlé de du
cruiser delfraissy qui vient de dire
mais
je vous dis ouvertement jeux de relais
mais des discussions pour que certaines
mesures d'urgence de soutien à la
consommation d'accès aux aides sociales
soit voté soit soit directement
appliquée puisque on s'apprête à rentrer
dans le débat budgétaire mais je viens
de vous donner l'exemple en valais où je
viens vous donner l'exemple et un
écriteau sur lequel je travaille qui
sera déposée avec nos sénateurs
attendez vous savez les n'est permis
tant de l'événementiel les extras c'est
maître d'hôtel qui vous servent dans les
cocktails qui vous servent dans les
conseils départementaux dans les
ministères à l'assemblée nationale ces
quinze à vingt mille personnes
je vous donne un exemple je ne dis pas
que c'est la panacée de tout ce qu'il
faut faire mais je vous donne un exemple
concret sur lequel avec un sénateur nous
sommes en train de forcer nous allons
déposer une proposition de loi pour dire
au gouvernement ses jumelles il faut
l'aimer par nation mois d'arrêt mon sens
de la politique économique
vous attendez aussi ce rééquilibrage
c'est absolument indispensable
aimer c'est non seulement pour venir en
aide aux 10 millions de pauvres moi je
suis très sensible ce lhermitte en
d'événementiel et il faut s'occuper des
permis dans l'événementiel mais vous
avez évoqué vous même le chiffre de 4 15
à 20 mille personnes on parle de 10
millions de pauvres dans notre pays je
vous aiderai juste en disant des choses
des accès la panacée je vous ai donné un
exemple où il ya d'action et lyon 1
millions de pauvres supplémentaires donc
il ya des questions très pratiques très
précises qui vont qui vous sont posées
est-ce que par exemple vous avez vous
allez décider de revenir sur les baisses
des apl que vous avez menées depuis 2010
est est ce que par exemple vous allez
rompre avec la politique qui a été menée
depuis trois ans sur la construction de
hlm qui se traduit aujourd'hui par une
baisse drastique du nombre de logements
accessibles ça va être dramatique pour
les familles les plus populaires cette
réduction du nombre de logements
accessibles alors répondez par exemple
aisément là dessus je les construction
de hlm des discussions qui effectivement
devront être posées dans le cadre du
projet de loi de finances les aides au
logement les ados le logement les aides
sociales moi je rappelle que je veux
bien qu'on puisse me dire la question
des appels mais je rappelle juste que
cette question des appels elle a été
budgétisée sous la mandature précédente
et sous la mandature socialiste si à la
belgique
rhodésie 50 euros elle a été supplanté
par une organisme hlm
qui assume qu'on ait mis en oeuvre cette
cette mesure un an mais nous nous fait
mal le procès d'avoir mou parce qu'il
est décidé à ces 2 2 parce que c'est
vrai attendez ne me fait pas le procès
nous des idées vous avez compte baisser
les abordant les plus politisés enfin
sous la mandature
ici la même 50 euros de baisse des apl
que vous avez fait supporter par les
organismes hlm ça se traduit
concrètement par une chute drastique du
nombre de logements accessibles dans
notre combat pour mettre d'accord là
dessus et on a tous les annonces du
gouvernement
moi je sens que je vais vous dire moi je
suis j'étais plutôt d'accord avec la
politique qui était qui a été décidée
d'urgence est venu effectivement pour
venir en aide
j'ai pas remplacés bien sûr qu'il faut
soutenir les entreprises fait ce qu'il
faut pas que notre tissu économique le
tissu industriel il soit au sortir de
cette crise encore plus affaiblie mais
regardez ce qui est en train de se
passer on n'arrête pas de nous expliquer
chaque jour que il y à un niveau
d'épargné de précaution des français
aujourd'hui qui atteint des niveaux
record les français ne consomment plus
qu'est ce qui se passe si demain matin
le gouvernement décide de mesures pour
aider la consommation pour pouvoir aider
le pouvoir d'achat des plus modestes et
des catégories moyens qu'elle vaut sera
pas reconstruit mais bien évidemment
quand vous venez les gens comme à
l'aller mais clara les secours populaire
je tape un peu la consommation aux
restos du coeur pour aller manger quand
vous donne un tout petit peu plus de
pouvoir d'achat vous allez le consommez
vous vous le voulez pas renié pas je
vous assure domergue là dessus que je
voudrais qu'on par apple en quête de
l'immanence parce que aider les ménages
les plus pauvres c'est d'abord bon pour
les ménages les plus pauvres pour qu'ils
puissent se loger se nourrir etc et
c'est bon si pour l'économie parce que
quand on aide les plus riches on ne sait
pas exactement où est ce que ça
ruisselle en tout cas on sait que ça les
rend plus riches quand on aide les plus
pauvres on sait que les pauvres vont
consommer parce qu'ils ont faim
un public défavorisé vulnérables et
pauvres mais qui était au travail qui a
bénéficié des des aides au chômage parmi
bien pour ça que j'ai tout à l'heure on
est les plus protecteurs depuis le début
de la crise sanitaire sinon et le bctq
c'est vrai mais avec des trous dans la
raquette ravel et maintenant ce sont ces
coups là qu'il faut fonder faut aussi
reconnaître ce qui a été tout à fait
alors
il ya eu des erreurs mais sur ce plan là
je pense que tout le monde est d'accord
pour dire que ce qui a été fait sur
cholet vraiment dans le bon sens pour
entamer
réellement on a montré aussi qu'il ya
des travailleurs pauvres voire très
pauvre aujourd'hui depuis le coc vide si
vous aviez en quelques minutes de trois
demandes précises au nom de la fondation
abbé pierre à faire puisque vous
apprêtez à rencontrer le premier
ministre je pense moment la politique du
logement c'est indispensable pour les
années qui viennent et pour maintenant
mais aujourd'hui le plus le plus rapide
c'est vraiment augmenter les minima
sociaux les gens ils ont besoin d'argent
ils n'ont pas besoin de banques
alimentaires ils ont besoin d'argent sur
leur compte en banque pour aller
s'acheter eux mêmes à m'en sers de mon
temps ah oui c'est un prime de mon temps
oui il ya le 500 euros le rsa pour vivre
personne peut vivre correctement oui
bien sûr qu'il faut revaloriser le rsa
et surtout il faut maintenant se poser
la question de son élargissement comment
on fait pour ces centaines de milliers
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
jeunes qui arrivent sur le marché du
travail qui n'auront aucune perspective
rapidement compte tenu de la situation
économique
encore une fois nous sommes un des rares
pays en europe où les minima sociaux ne
sont pas accessibles aux jeunes de 18 à
25 ans on va avoir une entrée de une
génération qui rentre là dont sacrifier
si on n'a pas une mesure d'urgence pour
ces publics ne répondait un mot de cette
enquête de l'inserm qui donne à un grand
portrait de ceux qui sont le plus
touchés par le cabinet je me tourne
pas une surprise mais pas du tout une
surprise ce sont ceux sont les plus
pauvres qu'est ce que vous vivez vous
très concrètement dans votre département
est ce que vous voyez
bien voilà les quatre qu'ovide positif
dans toute la population cependant cette
crise au pic de la crise au mois d'avril
j'avais employé cette expression le coc
vide tu mets les inégalités aussi et
donc c'est exactement ce que cette étude
montre effectivement en seine saint
denis on et ont davantage mort du duc au
vide et de ses conséquences parce que
c'est exactement quand vous avez les
appartements des bleus tiennent parfois
insalubres avec une famille nombreuse
que vous ne pouvez pas isolé la personne
qui est malade quand par ailleurs
contrairement à ce qu'on nous a dit vous
savez il ya une polémique sur la seine
saint denis qui ne se confient n'est pas
non non la coule la seine saint denis
elle sait bien confiné elle n'est pas
partie comme d'autres territoires à 20%
sa résidence secondaire elle est partie
le matin pour aller travailler pour
exercer ces métiers exposés caissière
livreur aide-soignante faire fonctionner
les transports en commun et porter le
masque et oui oui il est d'ailleurs le
président de la république le préfet
tout le monde a reconnu que globalement
les populations faisaient cet effort là
et donc c'est révélateur cette crise
elle a révélé une fois de plus les
inégalités sociales et territoriales
dans notre pays la région ile de france
est la région la plus riche de france
même d'europe mais qui est marquée par
des inégalités terrible contre
lesquelles nous n'agissons pas
collectivement suffisamment
sur cette étude qui effectivement on
aime n'est pas surprenante c'est quand
on est les plus pauvres
moi je suis décontracté moi j'ai encore
en images j'ai encore en images les
premiers décès liés ou kevin et
singulièrement en seine saint denis cet
agent de sécurité cette caissière des
cdc les voyez ces deux professions qui
nous servent au quotidien tous les jours
la caissière l'agent de sécurité et donc
je suis moi même à l'époque je dis moi
même que cette crise devait nous
conscientiser elle a rêvé en ou en tout
cas elle a fait ressortir en nous à la
surface des des évidences des évidences
sur lesquels nous sommes passés à côté
pendant des décennies c'est pas cette
mandature c'est une somme de mandature
qui est passé à côté donc ça nous a ça
doit nous conscients ça doit nous
permettre aujourd'hui d'avoir un autre
regard et j'espère que la majorité le
fera à l'occasion de ce combat on sera
là pour vérifier tout ça merci on va
s'arrêter là merci messieurs d'être
venus débattre de ce sujet évidemment
qui nous concerne tous vous étés avec
nos patrice duhamel parce qu'on va
parler un petit peu de vous à présent de
votre actualité vous ausculté je le
disais tout à l'heure depuis des années
la vème république à la fois son
histoire
ces personnalités ses précédents aussi
mais aussi mais aussi ses premiers
ministres
[Musique]
donc faire de matignon l'expression
rml et de michel rocard et les deux
michel rocard et lé les journalistes qui
ont fait ce documentaire formidable ya
quelques années qui s'appelait l'enfer
de matignon
betty mais c'est une expression qui est
rentré dans le langage commun c'est
l'enfer que vous racontez avec georges
marc benamou dans une série de quatre
documentaires qui s'appelle si la france
savait ils ont été diffusés sur lcp
mercredi qu'ils sont mis à l'honneur on
rencontre de l'histoire à blois dont lcp
partenaires c'est tout ce week-end c'est
23e rendez vous est ce que ça a été
compliqué d'abord de de convaincre tous
les anciens premiers ministres que vous
avez rencontrés alors j'en cite
quelques-uns à laurent fabius sur pierre
raffarin alain juppé idée de cresson de
se confier sur leur expérience non parce
que
il ya eu une idée je ne sais plus qui
l'a eue c'est pas moi je crois que c'est
georges bédard mines jean marc benamou
qu'il a eue le producteur est qui et qui
a interviewé ces quatre anciens premiers
ministres avec moi pendant une journée
ou à peu près c'est de les faire revenir
à l'hôtel matignon là où ils ont
travaillé comme premier ministre
interrogatoire oui mais je crois que
c'est là je crois que ça leur a fait
plaisir de revenir sur l'autre
guillemets le théâtre de leurs exploits
avec les bons moments les moments très
difficiles et quand vous avez le recul
nécessaire et en l'occurrence pour ces
quatre anciens premiers ministres il ya
le recul
c'est plus difficile quand si c'était
edouard philippe aujourd'hui ça serait
assez compliqué quand on a le nez encore
sur le guidon de tirer des leçons de ce
que on a vécu mais matignon jeu les
français le savent moins que l'elysée
c'est une lessiveuse on prend 50
décisions par jour on est sur le banc en
permanence et vous parliez de jean
pierre raffarin qui était un des quatre
premiers ministres qu'on a rencontrés et
qu'elle en a consacré ce documentaire
de 52 minutes il a dit il a une phrase
très bien il a sens de la formule il a
dit l'elysée c'est à palets matignon
c'est un hôtel tout est dit
excellente formule effectivement fourbus
l'enfer de matignon si on est bien une
pour qui cette expression fait sens et
est lé premier extrait dit qu'à matignon
il ya deux jours qui sont agréables le
jour où on arrivait les jours on part le
reste c'est l'enfer
ah oui l'expression l'enfer de matignon
vous considérez que laissait bien
choisie par tous cas ce qui me concerne
oui
ce départ pourquoi il détient tous les
jours moi parce que enfin je vais
pouvoir faire autre chose je vais pas
être attaqués tous les jours je
disparais des radars
voilà la seule femme première ministre
qui voit là n'a pas forcément aimer ce
passage écouter jean castex et le 23e
premier ministre de la vème république
on est en 2020 on est en 2020 là on est
quatre hommes c'est vrai je suis très
fier c'est pas tous les jours le sais
que c'est pas une critique contre ces
pays il ya souvent beaucoup de femmes
etc et puis vous êtes là mais
franchement
que edith cresson et était à ce jour la
seule femme premier ministre c'est quand
même tout à fait étonnant et je trouve
c'est anormal elle a fait comme les 22
autres premiers ministres de la saga
marc gicquel a fait des erreurs il a
fait plein d'erreurs en communication
etc on en parle avec elle dans ce
documentaire elle apporte les réponses
puis le téléspectateur aux juges mais
leur côté c'est l'enfer oui merkel un
kir qui dit moi j'ai jamais trouvé que
c'était l'enfer est ce que vous savez à
qui je pense est j'aime partir ses
devoirs philipp willi partir mais pour
quelques années cette expression est ce
que vous le croyez
je pense qu'il a vécu des moments toute
façon franchement
quand on est premier ministre on va pas
se plaindre hein quand on est en
activité ou conviennent quitter matignon
quand on a une crise comme la crise
sanitaire actuelle qui a eu avant la
crise des gilet jaune qui a ce tout ce
dont on vient de parler
le premier ministre sont pas là pour se
placer comme les présidents il travaille
pour le pour l'intérêt général je crois
tous les premiers ministres à tous ceux
que j'ai connus j'en ai connu beaucoup
parce que je les connais depuis
georges pompidou prêts dont je les
connais depuis chaban delmas vous voyez
ça fait si on enlève georges pompidou et
michel debré ça fait 21
faisait tout ce soit à ces biens soient
très bien connu
ils ont vécu des moments formidables et
souvent quand ils arrivent discours de
politique générale l'état de grâce du
premier ministre les bons sondages etc
et puis souvent c'est cesser pour eux
une galère c'est ce que j'évoquais tout
à l'heure parce que ils ont ils ont les
mains dans le
charbon du matin au soir et ce qui est
intéressant dans ses portraits notamment
celui de l'éducation c'est que
finalement avec le recul parce qu elle l
a été premier ministre qu'une dizaine de
mois c'était elle a été attaquée mais
vous ne pouvez pas y mettre vous êtes
trop jeune pour imaginer les attaques
machiste dont elle a été victime sur les
bancs de l'assemblée nationale le
raconte dans ce documentaire ça ça fait
ça fait 30 ans était en 91
c'est tout à fait extraordinaire et je
trouve qu'elle a été encore une fois
elle a fait des erreurs mais elle a été
très critiquée alors qu elle l avait
elle avait deux stratégies qui au jour
d'aujourd'hui
sont toujours les mêmes en termes
d'objectifs qui est une stratégie elle
était ministre des affaires européennes
mitterrand au moment du mur de berlin
quand même c'est quelque chose
elle était extrêmement militante
au moment où on parle de relocalisation
de souveraineté industrielle etc elle
avait une vraie vie j'aurai la politique
industrielle de la france a toujours été
facile ce poids de l'industrie française
en france on va regarder un deuxième
extrait justement sur aidé de cresson
parce que finalement pour comprendre son
parcours à gauche on se rend compte que
françois mitterrand très tôt l'avait
déjà repéré edith cresson début de sa
vie politique en participant à la
première campagne présidentielle de
françois mitterrand en 1965
[Musique]
membres du clan elle le suit à la
création du parti socialiste dont elle
devient l'une des responsables dès 1975
le parti socialiste présente avec edith
cresson
la de ses responsables nationaux c'est
dire l'importance que nous y attachons
vous avez déjà entendu des caisses
noires département malhabile dans son
langage le langage ne suffit pas
mais j'ai l'impression dans les 15 jours
ou trois semaines qui restent vous
apprécierez ses qualités de coeur et sa
capacité avec toi mr députés elle joue
dès le début une autre partition c'est
une femme de terrain qui déteste les
jeux politiques je ne fais pas
proprement parler de la politique pour
faire de la politique je me suis engagé
dans une direction bien déterminer qui
est celle de la gauche et plus
particulièrement du parti socialiste et
j'ai commencé en faisant en étant une
militante tout à fait à la base voilà
c'est formidable pour tous ceux qui ne
connaissent pas l'histoire de la vème
vous fait oeuvre au fond d'instruction
civique d'une certaine façon avec avec
c'est avec ces documentaires ils sont
remplis l'anecdote et de secret je
voulais vous poser une dernière question
politique avant d'accueillir antoine
glaser pourparlers d'afrique dans un
instant et de ski c'est bien de se
passer une bonne nouvelle avec la
libération de sophie petrona ce qu'on va
jouer la présidentielle selon vous vous
avez entendu jean pierre raffarin il
pense qu'elle se jouera sur la crise
sanitaire
les
je les ai toutes vécu de près les
campagnes présidentielles sauf celle de
souffle la première de 1965 au suffrage
universel
ça se joue beaucoup sur les hommes ça se
joue un peu sur les idées ça se joue
beaucoup sur les sur les femmes bien
entendu parce que j'aimerais bien que je
parle pas de marine le pen en
l'occurrence mais il faudrait quand même
qu'ils aient bientôt une femme
présidente de la république
donc les personnalités que les
programmes je pense ça se joue beaucoup
sur la capacité des candidats vus par
les français ça se joue toujours sur
deux ou trois sujets importants ça va se
jouer sur la sécurité sanitaire ça va se
jouer sur la sécurité tout court ça va
se jouer sur la situation de l'emploi
là où je partage ce que dit jean pierre
raffarin cc en l'occurence et et
notamment s'il est vrai que la crise
sanitaire va au moins avec cette
intensité jusqu'à l'été 2021 se jouait
sur la perception que les français
auront de la manière dont a été géré la
crise solitaire vous restez avec nous à
patrice duhamel je le disais on va
maintenant passer à notre décryptage la
dernière otage française dans le monde a
retrouvé les siens
[Musique]
bonsoir héros bonsoir plutôt antoine
glaser merci d'être là vous êtes
journaliste spécialiste de l'afrique
spécialiste du mali spécialiste aussi
des différents groupes terroristes au
sahel on va d'abord revoir cette image
sophie de pétrole un vous d'aller la
découvrir qui descend les marches de
l'avion qui la pause à la mi-journée à
villacoublay vous la découvrirez masqué
évidemment aux côtés d'emmanuel macron
le chef de l'état et qui retrouve et qui
retrouve les siens dans les bras de sa
famille de son fils aux côtés également
de jean yves le drian le ministre des
affaires étrangères elles sont toujours
très émouvante est particulièrement
forte aujourd'hui ces images oui oui oui
d'abord on peut plus on voit tout de
suite que ce fip et trône un événement
une personnalité elle même extrêmement
forte et la meilleure façon de parler on
sent bien que moi même par rapport à sa
famille on a l'impression que sa famille
est plus éprouvées qu'elle elle est
incroyable elle à elle a dit qu'elle
allait retourner à gao dans le nord du
mali
elle est dans une sorte de spiritualité
on voit bien league c'est ce qui la fait
tenir et oui et en plus c'est quand même
maintenant quasiment une sayen comme ils
disent là-bas je veux dire là toujours
vécu là bas je suis occupé des enfants
guingamp a été retourné là-bas en 2013
elle avait été obligée il avait été
obligé de s'enfuir par le consulat de
l'algérie et malgré tout ça n'était
quand même revenu sa vie est là-bas vous
qui vous intéresser à ce dossier de très
près vous avez été surpris par cette
libération est ce que tout s'est
accéléré oui j'étais d'autant plus
surpris que depuis le mois d'avril
2020 finalement à bamako on ne parlait
que la libération du chef de
l'opposition monsieur soumaïla cissé
j'avais déjà certain nombre de
négociations
quand elle a été libérée en même temps
avec deux autres otages italiens j'ai
franchement je suis par le secret des
dieux mais on sent bien que au départ
s'il s'agissait uniquement la libération
de du siège de l'opposition malienne
contre un certain nombre de djihadistes
et j'imagine on peut imaginer que la
france a fait pression compte tenu de la
perte ans de l'opération barque
anomalies fait pression sur les
nouvelles jantes les nouveaux militaires
qui ont pris le pouvoir en août 2000 va
à bamako en disant bah écoutez si vous
voulez vous libérer des djihadistes au
moins que se fit petronas quoi dans la
boucle il soit ils soient en même temps
libéré en même temps peut-être soumet
soumaïla cissé mais il faut que ça pique
au moins si vous devez libérer détient
disque la france a fait pression sur
vous expliquez nous qu'est ce qu'on sait
exactement à ce stade de cette
libération des djihadistes en
contrepartie vraisemblablement de la
libération de cet opposant malien qui
sont-ils précisément combien sont ils
est ce que ce sont uniquement les
autorités maliennes qui sont derrière
cet échange alors en fait tu vires on
dit toujours qu'il ya 200 djihadistes
qui ont été libérés mais faut pas voir
c'est pas de sens
tele2 terroristes vous avez environ une
vingtaine vraiment deux chefs rebelles
qui ont sans doute du sang sur les mains
et l'aurait sont beaucoup des petites
mains des gens qui s'occupent elles qui
étaient plutôt des chauffeurs briller si
on dit que son bilan est ce qu'on sait
déjà 10 des combattants l'on dit
toujours plusieurs milliers mais
franchement
oui mais parce qu'on ne sait pas encore
une fois il faut savoir de quoi de l'
échange de l échange à bas les choses la
libération jeudi
certains disent 206 dos tu 204 mais si
on a autant c'est que c'est pas
simplement il faut pas voir ça comme 210
échangés contre quatre
pépère personnes en otages il faut voir
ça comme finalement un processus au mali
qui est un processus qui est engagé une
forme de réconciliation nationale le
groupe qui détonnait sophie petrona
comme c'est en doute
al qaïda du maghreb islamique c'est un
monsieur qui s'appelle iyad rallye qui
est le chef d'un groupe qui s'appelle le
groupe pour l'islam et les musulmans et
donc lui s'éteint un touareg c'est un
touareg maliens et qui la plupart du
temps qu à la frontière entre l'algérie
et le nord du mali sa vie arrive à haute
en algérie qu'au nord du mali parce que
l'acteur masquer la région dont personne
ne parle c'est l'algérie qui a rien n'a
pu se faire de ce lien là sans les
algériens responsables aussi du
processus bien évidemment de processus
sinon vous et comment vous allez
expliquer que d'une télévision et pour
comment une télévision et moins chère à
kidal au nord du mali qu'à bamako certes
où passent pas par l'algérie bien
évidemment pour lui on se dit il ya une
opération barkan sur place nos soldats
sont sur place il ya peut-être parmi ces
djihadistes libéré bas des médias disent
que les français ont contribué avec
peut-être les maliens arrêtés patrice
duhamel c'est s'assumer
c'est quand même ce qui est vrai et ce
qui se dit dans les milieux comme on dit
un peu informés par exemple les
américains étaient assez réticent à la
libération d'un ou deux rebelles qu'ils
considéraient qu'habitué un américain
dans une opération anciennes donc je
pense a pas dû être facile mais je pense
que je pense c'est le poids docid
emmanuel macron je pense quelque part
encore une fois il y a il faut pas pas
voir ça simplement comme la libération
d'otages il faut voir ça comme un
processus je pense qu'eux mêmes et
macron a pas envie de s'embourber non
plus pendant des dizaines d'années s'ils
restent au pouvoir au sahel et donc s'il
ya une perspective qui se parlent entre
maliens parce qu'ils se parlent en ce
moment entre maliens entre monsieur
amadou koufa qui est le bol du centre le
seuil à deux rallyes qui parle avec les
touareg est haute pour la première fois
la junte il a fallu personnes et d'année
ne peut accepter un coup d'état mais ce
coup d'état et c'est jen a permis est ce
qui est pour la première fois dans le
nouveau gouvernement qui viennent
s'installer il ya quelques jours qui a
pour la première fois il ya des anciens
rebelles touareg du nord donc c'est un
processus en cours emmanuel macron ne
s'est pas exprimé honnêtement je sais
soit c'est parce que peut tout imaginer
on peut imaginer que ce fip et rona
avait peut-être un message on peut tout
imaginer peut imaginer l avait
apparemment refusé de s'exprimer donc
c'est difficile si elle ne l'exprimé pas
pour le président de s'exprimer aussi
soit le seul à parler donc il ya il ya
tout ça qui jouent et puis encore une
fois remercier qui le président l art
est obligé de remercier l'algérie ont
remercié les uns les autres c'est quand
même c'est une sacrée opération en a qui
viennent de se faire et il faut pas la
voir c'est intéressant comme libération
mais fait la voir comme un processus
j'ai pas de désengagement français parce
qu'ils sont là mais enfin encore une
fois toute la transition politique
absolument quel regard vous portez sur
cette analyse qu'on entend par an depuis
ce matin c'est une bonne nouvelle
je me posais que je vous pose c'est
est-ce que la france sauf à ce que le
gouvernement français ce que la
diplomatie française a été en première
ligne dans cette opération a été
vraiment comme on dit maintenant
proactive ou est-ce que ça a été
beaucoup plus large et qu'elle a fait
partie d'un ensemble de l'exécutif de
gouvernement qui ont contribué à aboutir
à cette solution beaucoup plus en
accompagnement elle était absolument pas
la manade qui est à la manoeuvre pour
les relations avec tout ce qu'ils
étaient l'algérie elle a été à la
manoeuvre sans doute aussi s'il ya eu
par exemple il a fallu est ce que la
france on dit toujours que évidemment en
dix jours ce sont les italiens payer des
rançons désirons 10 et les italiens
disent oui il ya des rançons qui ont été
payés également aussi du côté du mali
donc on a l'impression au fond ok cette
opération mali algérie puisque on
comprend que ce sont ces pays bas qui
étaient là pour à la manoeuvre l'argent
ça qu'ont passé c'est fini les rançons
c'est plus ça qui
commandait y demandait d'après ce qui se
disait à bamako il avait demandé d'abord
une rançon une rançon plus la libération
d'un certain nombre de des leurs qui
était emprisonné et dans un premier
temps ils ont refusé la rançon parce que
il n'y avait pas suffisamment de les
prisonniers des détenus qui avaient été
libérés mais encore une fois si vous
vous rappelez que le président macron à
vidy l'ennemi de barkan dans la région
c'est finalement le iie la vie 10 et
dash et c'est vraiment l'état islamique
al qaïda du maghreb islamique au départ
ce sont surtout les algériens qui ont
exporté dans leurs voisins du sud
l'ancien gia mais jeudi al qaïda legault
ce fameux groupe de yade rallye ceux qui
avaient détenaient les otages ce sont
des filiales locales et ses filiales
locales peuvent très bien à un moment
donné il ya deux rallyes négocier
puisque c'est une importance ce qu'il
est important il ya un accords d'alger
en ce moment pour négocier une sorte
d'autonomie
décentralisation on va pas le sco
fédéralisme de l'ensemble du nord du
mali et que ça soit que finalement si on
accorde à ces gens là une certaine des
positions au mali on pourrait le
retour de la paix le mot est prononcé
merci beaucoup antoine glaser pour ce
décryptage vous restez avec nous pour la
dernière séquence de cette émission
c'est le bloc notes tout de suite comme
tous les vendredis
[Musique]
bonsoir françois comment allez-vous on
ne se quitte plus en scène je me sens
pas fait ce qu'il faut répond me parler
en mars en grand ça va vite on nettoie
les les places à cause du coc vite je
vous rassure tout éco vie de free
maintenant comme on dit dans un bon
anglais ça tombe bien on va parler de la
campagne avait américaine avec vous vous
nous raconter la bataille d'image qui
sévit entre les deux camps oui dans la
série ça n'arrive qu'aux états unis mais
ça pourrait arriver en france je vous
parle aujourd'hui des publicités
négatives nettes négatives attendant le
texte alors le principe il est simple
ces hauts lieux comme en france de dire
du bien de son candidat on descend en
flèche son adversaire alors avec une
seule règle il y en a pas et pour le
coup pour faire comprendre pour que les
jeunes comprennent c'est un peu le mma
des hommes politiques c'est un peu tout
les atouts tout est permis alors pour
échapper exactement et pour échapper à
la caricature je vais vous montrer un
exemple ou là ce n'est pas l'agressivité
c'est pas les insultes qui sont utilisés
sont les moqueries ce sont ces l'humour
puis plus classique le sens inverse un
critique de baden et critique de kamala
harris alors là c'est les noms d'oiseaux
là c'est une pub du côté républicain
contre les démocrates
[Musique]
yves nanquette chemin voilà faut ni
alors folie en anglais c'est la foscam
halak a mal à la fosse fourni kamala et
slow joe joe le lent il a été même plus
loin donald trump dans les dernières
heures il a dit monstre la môme on
monstrueuse et alors nous tous on
termine là dessus le tout n'est pas de
faire des publicités négatives le tout
est de pouvoir dépenser des dizaines des
centaines de millions pour que les
américains les regarde et là problème
dans la campagne de donald trump il a
plus assez d'argent alors il peut pas
faire tous les états et oui là en train
de retirer des publics négative merci
beaucoup franc passe du revers à 25
jours de neige et des lecteurs vous
reviendrez vous revenez très vite bien
sûr on va terminer avec camille saféris
patrice duhamel camille saféris est un
charmant comédien qui est également
chroniqueur dans cette émission et qui
chaque semaine nous fait découvrir un
député un peu autrement il prend un
verre avec lui pour le décontracté un
peu camille qui avez vous rencontré avec
qui avez-vous traquer cette semaine eh
bien j'ai trinquer avec bénédicte
taurine elle est députée elle est fille
de l'ariège elle était prof de svt de
sciences et vie de la terre eh bien elle
est devenue députée elle a perdu son
statut alors par la suite eh bien
peut-être qu'elle devra reposer sa
candidature pour retrouver un poste mais
en attendant elle prend le train de nuit
parce que les pyrénées c'est très loin
elle vient une fois par semaine à
l'assemblée et le voyage prend la nuit
entière c'est un peu comme les députés
d'outre-mer qui au prennent l'avion où
elle c'est un train ou chez l'ancien un
des deux derniers en circulation assez
commun comme dans les années ça me
changeait donc en fait c'est des
voitures avec des couchettes allemange
par une première parce que sinon on est
six dans là c'est super c'est assez
particulier de dormir et déjà que les
preuves et vous arrivez à bien dormir
non non
[Rires]
c'est un rythme ça sert moi j'ai une
grosse larve saint principe est là c'est
un peu tendu pour moi moi je défends les
trains de nuit depuis toujours et du
coup c'est compliqué de défendre quelque
chose comme l'utilisent pas quoi et puis
qu'on ne sait pas comment ça marche
parce que c'est quand même une aventure
à toutes les semaines
alors vous avez vu bénédicte taurine
elle a un vrai look de l'yonne pas du
tout la députée en tailleurs classiques
et évidemment ben on le lui a reproché
à mai la tenue vestimentaire
d'épouvantail à faire des choses avec
cette magnifique crime et non c'est pas
beau là il faut s'attacher les cheveux
il faut alors j'ai tenté est de 2
de la tenue ça me ressemble pas
j'ai tenté de me when j'ai essayé de me
fondre un peu mieux mais c'est à dire
quoi de faire un chignon est d'attacher
les cheveux se veut s'attacher les
cheveux mais j'attache et les cheveux tu
vois ça donne quoi france à tignes tout
seul et c'est magnifique
personne ne donnait pas et voilà
d'accord alors c'est là où vous êtes
moins de reproches bon je sais pas si on
pourrait - de reproches mais c'est mieux
ça fait plus députés eh bien il paraît
alors dans la ferme où elle a grandi
celle de ses grands parents et bien il y
avait plein d'animaux et aujourd'hui
encore bénédicte taurine à une jument
des lapins et une vache qui s'appelle
soizic et qui à 19 ans c'est donc une
bâche à la retraite qu'elle a choisi de
recueillir choisi que oui c'était une
vache équité at oui j'aimerais le voir à
côté des portes comme les histoires de
vache
16x devenu la vache qui était à des
enfants normalement une vache en fin de
vie comme ça elle est vouée à l'abattoir
et là du coup je les prive d'un patio la
ferme c'est quand même un travail
permanent quoi ça commence tôt le matin
est uni tard le soir c'est vrai que
c'est un travail permanent mais c'est
notre rythme escape en parallèle la
mongolie ferme et l'assemblée est
comparable c'est que on ne pense jamais
à autre chose il ya moi je vois pas
passer des semaines en fait il n'ya pas
de week-end n'y a pas de coupure du coup
on n'a jamais vraiment de rupture entre
entre ce conflit est ce qu on est donc
c'est la même chose qui ne ferment on
n'est pas les matches mais
voilà merci beaucoup camille il pourrait
vous inspirer ses députés 7 bénédicte
taurine patrice duhamel pour un
documentaire à venir on se parle les
animaux mais sympathique merci en tout
cas d'être venu sur le plateau de lcp
antoine glaser françois durpaire je vous
dis excellent week end à tous si on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine très belle
soirée
[Musique]